neue provokationen aus nordkorea kim
jong-un lässt schon wieder raketen in
den himmel steigen
das abgeschottete land nordkorea hat
laut berichten der nachbarländer japan
und südkorea neue raketentests
durchgeführt
erst in der vergangenen woche hat die
selbst erklärte atommacht überschall
raketen getestet
paketen die sechsmal schneller sind als
der schall
eigentlich sind solche testens durch die
un untersagt
doch am dienstagmorgen soll eine
potenziell atomwaffenfähige rakete aus
dem landesinneren ins offene meer
abgefeuert worden seien
die usa und andere länder des
un-sicherheitsrates sehen die tests als
gefahr für die regionale sicherheit an
nordkorea testet regelmäßig raketen
unterschiedlichen typs die
kommunistische führung in pyongyang
treibt dabei seit jahren vor allem die
entwicklung von raketen voran die mit
atomsprengköpfen ausgerüstet werden
können
und versetzt so nicht nur die
nachbarländer sondern die ganze welt in
angst und schrecken